well our trip to the grocery store has
certainly changed dramatically in the
last year
an entrepreneur created something out of
necessity to make us all feel a little
bit safer while we're grocery shopping
and she believes that it is still going
to be a necessity long after covid is
gone
kirsten joyce has the story denise when
the pandemic hit
mom and entrepreneur andy barnes rubin
was scared to go to the grocery store
and when she did a little research about
just how dirty grocery carts were
it only confirmed her worst fears
grocery carts are
more disgusting and have just as much
bacteria as a public toilet
and that that freaked me out
and that's research from the university
of arizona's department of environmental
science
well andy wanted to create a
one-size-fits-all liner that covers the
entire grocery cart including the handle
for carts as large as say costco and as
small as trader joe's
within a few months she had a prototype
a patent she got it manufactured and
launched it nationwide in august
right now she offers a recyclable
shopping cart liner
you get a package of 10 sells for about
19.99
and very soon she'll be offering another
option
i discovered that a lot of people wanted
something that you could just throw in
the washing machine so
within about two weeks we will be
getting our cart safe
washable liners so that's really
exciting because i know
you know there's people that don't like
the recycled plastic but they're gonna
love this so i wanted to make sure that
whatever people were more comfortable
with that they had the options
she says even when the coronavirus goes
away we still got to battle the germs
and dirt and she says this device will
keep her family
safe and yours andy is currently
pursuing a good housekeeping seal of
approval
for the product